Провідника Івана війна застала на світанку 24 лютого у потязі, на маршруті Львів-Запоріжжя.
Жінка одна плакала і каже: вам нічого не повідомляли?
Я кажу: "Ні", каже: "Обстріл іде Дніпропетровська".
Я не повірив, почав дивитися Фейсбук, новини, і виявилося, що по всій Україні обстріли.
Приїхали ми на Запоріжжя з запізненням, і нам сказали, що буде евакуація.
Від початку війни "Укрзалізниця" евакуювала вже приблизно 3,7 мільйона людей
з північних, східних і південних регіонів до Західної України.
Окрім важливої інфраструктурної ролі, провідниця Вікторія вірить в терапевтичну дію поїздів.
Жінка працює провідницею 10 років.
Хоча її звичний маршрут Костянтинівка-Київ, тепер Вікторія їздить на евакуаційних потягах.
Її домівка в Донецькій області.
Жінка не була там вже два місяці.
Перший місяць війни бригада евакуаційного потягу прожила на робочому місці.
Тепер працівники мають змогу прийняти душ і попрати речі в Запоріжжі,
хоча умови залишаються не найкомфортнішими.
За словами Вікторії, багато пасажирів евакуаційних потягів перебувають у пригніченому стані.
Також провідниця перевозила людей з інвалідністю і сотні дітей.
Бригада потяга намагається всім допомогти, як може.
Найстрашнішим моментом для провідниці став обстріл потяга, який відправився зі станції лише на 10 хвилин пізніше за її.
За даними "Укрзалізниці", за два місяці війни 109 залізничників загинули та ще 127 - отримали поранення.
Російські війська регулярно обстрілюють залізничну інфраструктуру.
Однак за словами Вікторії, практично всі працівники державного підприємства залишилися працювати.
Це підтвердив у коментарі DW й очільник "Укрзалізниці" Олександр Камишін.
Провідниця Вікторія також планує працювати на залізниці далі.
Жінка не вважає, що в її діях є якийсь героїзм. Каже, вона любить свою роботу.
Іван також працює два місяці війни без відпочинку. Однак сказати, що він призвичаївся, чоловік не може.
Воно якось давило на психіку, а коли ти вертаєшся назад, у Запоріжжя,
і пустий вагон і на станціях сирени, якесь таке було відчуття, сон був якийсь неспокійний, дуже заморений.
І все ж, щойно робота на залізничному фронті закінчиться, чоловік готовий піти на реальний.
"Укрзалізниця" наклала бронь на пів року,
тобто нас до призиву в армію не беруть.
Але якщо бронь закінчиться і призовуть, то піду воювати...
Окрім пасажирів, "Укрзалізниця" перевозить тисячі тонн гуманітарного вантажу.
А також допомагає західним лідерам дістатися до Києва і Львова.
Олександр Камишін називає це "залізною дипломатією".
За умов, коли авіасполучення не працюють, а на дорогах сильні затори і вища вірогідність обстрілів,
"Укрзалізниця" стала основним способом сполучення для всієї України.